On your left
so when they needed us we could fight
the battles
that they never could
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be a bit of a sad video
because chadwick boseman has passed away
a lot of you asked me to make a video
about it explain what happened so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to donate
the earnings from this youtube video to
a cancer charity like
f cancer i don't have any kind of
fundraiser or anything special like that
set up
this is just a really sad really sudden
announcement that they made that he had
passed away from cancer
so if you yourself or you know someone
who's suffering from something similar
and you want to do that
just please donate to a charity of your
own choosing but if you're not sure what
happened you're still in shock
chadwick boseman's official twitter
account through his family announced
last night
that he had passed away after a long
battle the past four years
with stage four cancer apparently he'd
been keeping his diagnosis
secret from the public but he'd been
making all these movies so long this is
his imdb
page from the last four years while he
knew that he had been suffering from
cancer going through treatments
between movies that means while he was
working on the captain america civil war
movie while he was working on black
panther avengers infinity war and
avengers end game
between all those movies he was
suffering from cancer going through
crazy surgeries
not letting anyone know that's how much
he endured and how hardcore he was
so back in 2014 marvel first announced
him on stage as
black panther for captain america civil
war that movie didn't happen until 2016
obviously
but during 2016 is when he discovered
that he had stage three cancer
then for the next four years he
proceeded to go through a number of
treatments
a bunch of really hardcore surgery while
they were working on the black panther
movie so that was going on
while he was going through all this and
then obviously we just had avengers
infinity war and avengers end game
and even though he looked really good
during those movies apparently things
had just gotten
worse recently this year so earlier this
year he had posted a video of himself
looking very thin unhealthy people were
afraid they didn't know what was going
on everyone was freaking out
now we have a little more information
about what was happening around that
time
so of course marvel kevin feige some of
the big people
that knew him his friends and family
have issued statements
this is what kevin feige's statement was
he says chadwick's passing is absolutely
devastating he was our t'challa
our black panther and our dear friend
each time he stepped on set he radiated
charisma and joy
and each time he appeared on screen he
created something truly
indelible he embodied a lot of amazing
people in his work
and nobody was better at bringing great
men to life he was as smart and kind and
powerful and strong as any person he
portrayed
now he takes his place alongside them as
an icon for the ages
the marvel studios family deeply mourns
his loss
and we are grieving tonight with his
family the disney ceo
obviously the russo brothers who had
done a lot of work with him also issued
statements that were similar
personally in my own life my mother is
actually a cancer survivor so i had to
go through something similar with my
family
it's never easy when something like this
happens especially watching someone
suffer through something like that for
so long because it's not something
that's quick it takes a long time
this is actually a video clip of him
talking about working with
stage 3 cancer patients little kids
before the black panther movie came out
and what it meant to him
while he himself was suffering from
stage 3 cancer
throughout our filming i was
communicating with them
um knowing that they were both terminal
and and what they said to me is
and their parents said they just they're
trying to hold on
until this movie comes
and i
to a certain degree you hear them say
that and you're like
like wow that's
like i gotta get up and i gotta get up
and go to the gym
i gotta get up and go to work um you
know
i gotta learn these lines i gotta work
on this accident uh
you know seeing how devoted all of my
castmates are
and knowing that that that that that
will be something meaningful
to them but it's to a certain degree
it's a humbling experience because
you're like this can't mean that much to
them you know
but seeing how the world has taken us on
seeing how the movement is how it's
taking on a life of its own
i realized that they anticipated
something great and
i think back now to a kid and just
you know uh waiting for christmas to
come waiting for my birthday to come
waiting for a toy that was going to that
i was going to get a chance to
experience or a video game
i did live life waiting for those
moments
and so it put me back in the mind of
being a kid
just just to experience those two little
boys
um anticipation of this movie and when i
found out that they
yeah it's it's it means a lot
so listening to him talk about that what
it meant to him you just have to imagine
how hard he was fighting for himself and
for those little kids while this was all
going on
so for those of you asking yes marvel
didn't know about his diagnosis
when they were making all those movies
it would have been impossible for him to
hide it from
everyone and as for the reason why he
didn't make it public is probably just
because he didn't want to be pigeonholed
typically when someone announces
something like that that's the only way
they get portrayed in the media
and he probably didn't want to
overshadow the weight of what he was
doing or
color people's perception of him and
think about all the little kids that
idealized black panther he probably
didn't want to take that away from them
i get that a lot of you are still in
shock and you're asking all kinds of
questions about the upcoming marvel
movies black panther 2
avengers 5 how are they going to honor
his memory without doing something
distasteful
in those upcoming movies i think it's a
little crass to just immediately start
thinking about what's going to happen to
black panther 2 right now
obviously the world has to mourn we have
to process this you can't start thinking
about all those movies right away
but typically what disney and marvel
does when someone passes away like this
they do have some way of memorializing
them
in upcoming movies for instance when
stan lee passed away you probably
remember that they had this special
marvel movie intro featuring all of his
cameo characters
instead of the regular marvel characters
from the intro as of me posting this
video ryan coogler hasn't issued any
kind of statement on his passing or any
kind of memorial but he doesn't really
have social media accounts so it's
probably going to be a while before he
says something
he was very close to him so just like
everyone else he's probably still in
shock right now trying to process what
just happened
i think the best thing you can do right
now is just remember how
important he was as a person the
characters that he played
he wasn't just in marvel movies he made
a lot of other movies about famous
people
but if you are a big marvel fan just
remember how important he was as a
person and as a character within the
universe how important the black panther
film was to pop culture this is him
talking about the importance of the film
in the world itself and how important it
was for him to get this character right
and what he felt like it meant to the
world
i mean we've had wesley snipes before so
i got it i gotta give him
but but on this stage and
definitively a superhero in this way
it is it is a new concept just it's the
it's the whole cast and it's the fact
that it's this big
yeah it is like a sea change moment
i do love that he totally gives a shout
out to wesley snipes blade talking about
the first
big african-american superhero in the
marvel universe because blade is a
marvel movie even though it was made by
new line instead of marvel studios at
the time
so i think we're all in agreement that
we can say with confidence that no
marvel is not going to recast the role
of t'challa
that would be the biggest slap in the
face to his memory in real life to the
fans to his family
if they decide to continue with the
black panther 2 movie it would be more
likely that shuri would take the mantle
of black panther like she does in the
comics
and they find some legit way for the
movie to reference what happened to him
in real life without being distasteful
about it the right story to honor his
legacy as a person
and as a character so everyone just post
your favorite memories of him in the
comments what he meant to you what the
character meant to you
and please stay healthy 2020 has already
taken
so much from us it does not need to take
any more
there is a lot of marvel stuff happening
later this year maybe they'll issue some
more statements about what's going on so
if they do of course i'll do a video
about that explaining
long before this had happened of course
i'd already done a couple black panther
2 videos about easter eggs and teasers
and what marvel had already set up you
can click here if you want to learn
about that
and you can click here for my marvel new
mutants movie review
so thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe in wakanda forever!